I don't need to move across the ocean to
experience violence for being queer uh
here is a transact there's a sh didn't
want to curse there's a lot of these
videos out there this is just one here's
a trans activist explaining how being
transed in America is very similar to
being a gazin during a war go I keep
getting comments that if I was in Gaza I
would be killed for being queer and
first off there are queer people in Gaza
and they're being killed for being
Palestinian secondly I don't need to
move across the ocean to experience
violence for being queer I literally had
to evacuate my place 6 months ago
because people were so violent and
sending me death threats literally
hunting me down for being trans this is
in the United States of America the
United States of America for Trans
people is in stage seven and 8 Palestine
is in 9 and 10 there is a reason why the
United States was the only country who
vetoed a United Nations security Council
resolution there is a reason why our our
government is so adamant about saying
level the place there is a reason why
this country continues to ignore what's
happening in Palestine because our
country is built on genocide and by the
way Hitler he also attacked queer people
there's a reason why we were forced to
wear pink triangles and also he
literally got his ideas for
concentration camps from the United
States of America history is repeating
itself right now and how dare you try to
weaponize my queerness in order to
manipulate me to to support genocide I
will never stand by Israel's actions I
won't stand by Israel in general and if
you're queer and you are standing with
Israel you're wrong and you really need
to take a step back and evaluate your
morals and value look frankly I don't
think you need me to analyze any of that
so instead I'd like to show you a 10 or
15 second video that I found of that
dude putting on his
makeup oh this is just feel look
fabulous look at you and a little more
on the cheeks and a little more
on
like do I have to add commentary to what
we just saw it's all so stupid anyway
here's a dude in address leading a pro
Palestine protest in Washington
DC free free Palestine free free palese
free free palese free free Palestine
free free palese all right I want to be
very clear about this if any of you know
who that man in a dress is who's also
wearing a mask outdoors I have no idea
why uh I will put
$110,000 I am not kidding
$10,000 to send that man in addess to
Gaza you know what $20,000 I you know
what I mean fly first class I'll get you
a couple nice dresses we'll get you some
anol o blanx that's a type of shoe Jimmy
choose whatever you want and I'd like to
send you to Gaza you masked dude in a
dress screaming for people who would
love to behead you it is it is so
extraordinary like you can't see what's
going on right now and that that's again
I do think there is a silver lining
Happening Here there really is something
happening here I know everything seems
worse right now right like there there's
something unbelievably horrific happened
and and there's now still Fallout from
that and there's there's we could
potentially be on the verge of World War
II there's an existential battle
happening right now like there's all of
that but the Silver Lining is good
decent people who I get it they're quiet
they're not out there protesting and
screaming so we're only seeing the
crazies but good decent people see
videos like that and they get they get
what's going
on